dans des conditions pareilles difficiles
voire impossible de se déplacer
la neige et les forts mènent la vie dure
aux Américains l'une des journées les
plus achalandées de l'année dans les
aéroports du pays verrocaumar pour bien
des voyageurs
je veux simplement rentrer auprès de ma
famille dit-il un cadeau pour sa fille
en main
si la musique adoucit les mœurs c'est le
temps ou jamais
c'est un peu fou déplore cet autre
passager je ne sais pas quand je
pourrais partir
[Musique]
le secrétaire au transport explique que
des milliers de vols sont annulés des
alertes de froid sont en vigueur pour
des dizaines de millions d'Américains de
la frontière canadienne dans des états
comme le Montana et le royauming
jusqu'au Texas à la frontière avec le
Mexique
certaines régions enregistrent les
températures les plus froides en une
décennie ou plus jusqu'à moins 45 degrés
Celsius dans le centre des États-Unis le
Service météorologique américain parle
d'une tempête comme on en voit qu'une
fois par génération
ce n'est pas une journée de tempête
comme quand vous étiez enfant insiste le
président Biden la situation pourrait
être carrément dangereuse par endroits
c'est à prendre au sérieux
plusieurs États ont déclaré l'état
d'urgence comme loklahoma et le Kentucky
le feront froid doit s'intensifier
demain et persister encore quelques
jours ici Sébastien Desrosiers
Radio-Canada Montréal